Disc extre post by
jpma Yes
me It
's very interesting to be able to express what I imagined in such a big form in front of a large audience, but
me
goo
[Music]
Asako Kitamura Nebuta production
Nebuta is a person who skeletons with a wire, puts paper on it, and turns on electricity to the inside.
[Music
] Nebuta is made in about a year considering the concept of Nebuta.
However, the height of the old meter is about 5 meters including the trolley.
Well, every year the idea is various movies, TV, going to
museums, watching books, but the creator of the snow.  I think that life
, or something
that happens in a living family, is influenced by the blast.
[Music] The
Nebuta Festival seems to have been going on for about 300 years
.  There are 22 big mountain cars at the Nebuta Festival
. The reason why I started calling Nebuta is that my father was also making 2 and he
was watching his father and protecting him very hard.
I don't want to get sleepy feelings, so
I say that I'm the only woman's sound 2 c now.
Before I reviewed it as a web etc., it was an elevator policy.  It is
said that is made by men, and in the
past it was said that it was difficult for women to express a masculine seam like
that,
but the current situation in Japan is getting stronger.
I think that even women can express that kind of courage
.
I
didn't expect to receive such a wonderful prize at that time when my work received the Nebuta Grand Prize, so to be honest, I don't really
feel it.  I'm
really surprised
[Music] It's
2 next year, but I want to do it so that I can make the best work at that time without paying too much
[Music]